hello Steve coffin here we're off and
running with the natural language
society I've had some more positive
response so I'm going to step up the
frequency of these of these podcasts
natural language what do you mean again
we mean that its natural to speak more
than one language and that we should
learn naturally I avoid the term
multilingualism because I think many
people would be very happy to speak just
one more language some people can speak
three or four or five more languages but
let's start with one many people had a
difficult time at school even learning
one language and as I say that's because
the languages in school are not taught
naturally they're not taught in a way
that basically matches our brain learns
the brain takes time to learn the brain
based on a lot of input will gradually
form labels and rules that enable it to
deal with the new phenomena that's how
we learn everything in life and the
brain is constantly learning based on
the input that it receives what happens
in school is that a teacher decides what
we're going to learn the teacher decides
what the subject is going to be the
teacher decides which parts of the
language we're going to have to learn
today and then the teacher tries to test
us on whether we learned that today well
as I just explained and based on
significant brain research and
particularly as explained in Memphis
pizzas recent book called learning and
the school of life the brain takes time
and the brain takes time to put together
the groups of neurons and create the
relationships between these neurons that
are going to enable you to learn that
it's not because it was explained to you
today that you learn it today so but
what is also pointed out in Spencer's
book is the more relevant the
information the more meaningful and the
more enjoyable the better we learn so
that if we are interested in flowers and
we're meeting about flowers we're going
to learn
more language you for reading about
flowers in German and the words are
going to be meaningful and relevant to
us and we're going to remember them but
if we're not interested in car mechanics
then if we read content on car mechanics
or on politics we won't learn so it's
interesting I've been on this called a
listserv where various language teachers
exchange views on different subjects and
a number of language teachers
particularly women we're saying how they
really enjoyed using children's stories
for adult ESL learners or adults who
were struggling with reading and then a
couple of people who were to judge by
their names of different ethnic ethnic
origins not through english or typically
English sounding names and they said
well you know actually it's a bit
insulting for an adult to be given
children's stories to read well of
course the group of of the love of the
language teachers in particular the
ladies I don't want to be accused of
being sexist here laser said well how
can you be so narrow-minded how can you
say it's insulting my students love it
one of them said you know there was a
saying that if the teacher likes to
dance everybody likes to dance one
another one said you know i haved in
France and until I did their children's
stories there are many cultural
references that I couldn't understand I
love children stories every likes George
and I said to myself and then I come a
little commented here I am sure there
are learners who like children stores
Evans I'm sure there are some I don't
think there are many I know I don't I
know that when I learned languages I
didn't like children's stories I didn't
like descriptions of the local moon
harvest festival or whatever i can
remember having a japanese lesson where
they talked about irises and blue flags
to flowers i still don't know the names
of those flowers in japanese it's not a
subject that interests me surely if
we're going to have natural language
learning successful land clearing the
first thing is
that the learner has to have the
opportunity to choose the content the
subject matter that they're going to
learn from but has to be number one and
some learners are not comfortable with
doing that they want the teacher to
spoon feed or whatever that's fine but
then they learn then the teacher it's
very important that they sort of bring
out yet the learner to talk about things
that are of interest because we know
from experience and we know from brain
research that the content matter has to
be relevant interesting enjoyable
meaningful and the only person who can
determine what is relevant interesting
and meaningful and enjoyable is the
learner him or herself so I just a
quickie today I'm going to do more of
these little bit shorter talk about
different subjects that relate to
natural language learning and also to
how we can get more of a movement behind
natural language learning we're going to
talk about all these things I'm going to
make them shorter under six minutes and
I'm going to do the more off but today
the message is natural means let's learn
the way the brain learns let's make sure
that the learning content is of interest
to the learner thank you very much